[Musique]
pegi 16
vous connaissez l'expression
ne rencontrez jamais vos héros
et d'un mois
j'ai fait
et c'était génial
les avenger et oui comme dans mes rêves
les plus fous
bonjour san francisco tort de n'y aller
voir tout de suite et c'est de me suivre
alors ça c'est tout de suite plus
intéressant
on va faire ça vite
sécuriser le pont ces femmes ne doivent
pas entrer dans la ville du mans les
aline
wade explose
comment ça se passe je vois des gens
pris au piège et des petits homards
mettrait en colère c'était une blague
d'orteils l'humour les gars ils ont des
blindés pulsar
moi
[Musique]
acura
tous les torts les câbles
4 qu'est ce qui se passe là où
thaçi verra comment ça se passe on
devrait rentrer non
il reste encore des civils sur le pont
c'est fait avoir non c'était peut-être
comptés ou bien ce sont des meurtriers
les avengers ont-ils un risque pour la
société c'était la question bruce
c'était ça la question
oui on a tous perdu quelque chose ce
jour là mais l'histoire ne s'arrête pas
là
[Musique]
bon qu'est ce qu'on l'attende